good morning my name is Michael Kelleher
program director of The Donald Windham
sandy m campbell literature prizes at
Yale University on behalf of the by
Nicki Rare Book and Manuscript library
welcome to the 2014 Windham Campbell
prize winners announcement in his
introduction to Donald Windham short
story collection the warm country am
forester rights to my mind the most
important thing about Donald Windham is
that he believes in warmth he knows that
human beings are not statues but
contained flesh and blood and a heart
the spirit of generosity as well as a
love of literature and a profound
sympathy for his fellow writers led
Windham to establish the prizes the
Wyndham Campbell prizes call attention
to literary achievement and provide
writers with the opportunity to focus on
their work independent of financial
concerns awards are made to english
language writers at all stages of their
careers from anywhere in the world
nominees must have one published book or
one professionally produced play to
their credit this year there were 64
nominees from 16 countries from this
group eight were selected to receive the
prize each will receive a citation
diploma and 150 thousand dollars to
support their writing the prizes will be
conferred at a ceremony and literary
festival here on campus September 15 to
19 2014 information about Prize winners
will be available at windham campbell
org following this announcement today's
recipients did not know that they had
been nominated or that their nominations
had progressed through a year-long
process involving 51 nominators jurors
and judges all of whom agreed to work
anonymously I'd like to thank them for
the fine work they've done in nominating
and selecting this year's prize winners
I'd also like to thank the Wyndham
Campbell prize steering committee the
office of the president and the director
and staff of the by Nikki library for
the
support I will return to the podium to
answer questions following this
announcement but now it's my pleasure to
introduce yells president Peter Salva
thank you very much Michael thank you
all for coming it's hard to believe it's
been a year since our last announcement
in this very location yell as you know
is honored to be the home of the wyndham
Campbell prizes and to the wyndham
Campbell prizes festival and we're
especially grateful to the late donald
windham and sandy campbell for creating
this legacy it's always humbling to
stand in the glow of this tower of books
one of the great monuments to human
intellectual achievement really one of
the great monuments to human
intellectual achievement in the world I
can't think of a more appropriate
setting to announce the winners of a
global literary prize than here at the
by two key I feel certain the winners
will one day add their inscriptions to
this monument as Michael noted all nine
Prize winners will come to yell in
September during last year's festival
the entire campus lit up with excitement
as we celebrated the work of our prize
winners with talks classes performances
readings film screenings and impromptu
conversations about these great writers
it was an inspiration to kick off my
first year as yells president amid such
a buzz it's my feeling that by
establishing the prizes at yell Donald
Donald Wyndham knew that he was placing
them in the care of a friend who shared
his concerns that writers be supported
and that their achievements not go
unrecognized so I look forward to
welcoming
all of this year's prize winners to Yale
in September and I hope their work will
continue to inspire readers on campus
and around the world there are eight
Prize winners this year three each of
the categories of drama and fiction and
two in nonfiction so the wyndham
campbell prizes for drama are awarded to
from the united states kia cars run
through her command of dramatic
spectacle kiya kar throng places often
unheard and marginalized characters
within historical and political context
that gives their lives and urgent and
poetic resonance from the United Kingdom
Sam Hall Croft samho coughs plays
explore the routinized and expressive
registers of language gesture and
role-playing walking the uncomfortably
thin line between spectatorship and
complicity from Australia Noel Jana
cheve Scott no eliana cheska brings
innovative stagecraft and a questioning
voice two plays that translate cultural
and political tensions into drama as
complex as it is illuminating now the
wyndham Campbell prizes for fiction are
awarded to from Pakistan nadeem aslam
nadeem aslam definitely crafted novels
explore historical and political trauma
with lyricism and profound compassion
from the United Kingdom Jim Crace
Jim crazes ever varied novels return us
to the body to ceremony and to community
in a disenchanted world transforming the
indifferent and the repugnant alike into
things of beauty from Sierra Leone
Aminata fauna I mean at the foreigner
rights through and beyond personal
experience to speak to the wider world
in subtle in subtly constructed
narratives that reveal the ongoing
aftershocks of living through violence
and war the wyndham Campbell prizes for
nonfiction are awarded to from India
pankaj mishra pursuing high standards of
literary style pankaj mishra gives us
new narratives about the evolution of
modern asia he charts the journey from
the Indian small town to the metropolis
and rebuffs imperialist cliches with
equal Verve from the United States and
Canada John valiant John valiant writes
gripping narratives that combines
science geography history and
anthropology to convey his passionate
commitment to preserving natural
resources in an environmentally
threatened world we thank these winners
for the ways in which their work has
enriched us enriched all of us and we
congratulate them on this incredible
achievement I look forward to meeting
all of them in September once again I
want to thank all of you for joining us
here this morning and especially Michael
for your great work on this program
thank you all very much
so we have a microphone that's set up
over here for anybody would like to ask
questions if you could walk up to the
microphone because we'd like to have the
questions be heard on the video that's
streaming live around the world right
now does anybody have any questions that
they would like to ask are there any
members of the press here you don't have
to be with the press to ask a question
yeah could you thanks Jim I was just
wondering if you could outline how many
judges there are who are part of this
nominating process and talk a little bit
about why there were eight awards rather
than then I think there were nine last
year correct there are 30 nominators
approximately each year and those
nominators change each year each
nominator makes two nominations so
that's where we get our nominees from
there are three juror panels prize
Jerry's that meet one for each category
each jury has three members so there are
nine jurors across the three categories
and then the final committee the
selection committee has eight members
and so I think that adds up to somewhere
near 50 I'm a language person the eight
the reason there were only eight Prize
winners this year is that when the prize
selection committee meets they try to
come to a consensus on all the prize
winners all eight prize winners were
consensus prize winners everybody agreed
a hundred percent that these should be
the prize winners this year in the
category of nonfiction there were there
were other nominees that made the final
list but no consensus could become to
buy the selection committee and it's
their prerogative to award fewer awards
rather than the full number if they feel
that that is in their best interest own
this year was really about not being
able to come to consensus and deciding
it would be better to not select
somebody if they couldn't come to a
consensus on those people
I also wondered is it is it a
prerequisite that the winner has to be
available to come to new haven for the
festival yes when we so what happens is
we we met on Monday all day long and
select the prize winners and wrote the
citations and i spent all of tuesday
trying to contact the prizewinners i
call them on the phone I clay EDD
McMahon I say hi I'm this guy from Yale
University and by the way you just 150
thousand dollars and it's it's very
exciting it's a very emotional day you
know people's responses are incredibly
powerful to experience and there as far
as I could tell nobody had any idea that
they were nominated and that's how we
chose to do it did I answer your
question I feel like I missed something
okay good anybody else Peter well they
were they ranged from tears one of the
prizewinners i want i won't out anybody
so I don't embarrass them but one of the
prizewinners at one point was was was
was quite moved and asked me if I could
just continue to talk for a while
because she was unable to respond
verbally at a certain point another one
of our prize winners was really
appreciated because she had recently had
surgery and had had to use Medicaid in
order to be able to pay for the surgery
and you know I mean that's I think
that's a really profound statement about
the way a lot of artists have to live in
the present and and really speaks to the
need for a prize like this and I think
that was that was really one of the most
moving responses I got this year yeah so
it's it's it's it's a very powerful
experience to talk to everybody during
the course of the day and it really I
think speaks to the way that this prize
is evolving to support writers in a way
that I think Donald Windham would have
been very
crowd oven and and honored to be a part
of yes yes all right waiting for the
microphone I'm just curious are there
ever people that you call and they don't
believe it yes I had one of the
prizewinners I was chasing down for the
better part of 24 hours i sent several
emails i tried to make friends with them
on linkedin on facebook and they finally
wrote back to me late in the day on
Tuesday and said I kept seeing these
emails and I thought it was one of those
sort of Nigerian hoax emails and that
that was the case several times nobody
this year asked me for firm
documentation outright but I did I did
have a letter prepared from the director
of the by Nikki that went straight out
to everybody after we'd made our phone
call so anybody else okay well thank you
very much and congratulations once again
to the 2014 Prize winners
I should note that they did all agree to
come so you will get a chance to meet
all eight Prize winners during the prize
festival which will take place September
15 to 19 2014 here at Yale University